do back in the day when I was young and
you heard that doorbell go off hey
everybody tried to get to the door to
see who it was every kid in the house
man
you could be crying immediately you dry
your tears up you put on some powder
whatever flour sugar whatever you got to
do to make it look like you wasn't
crying to tighten up to get to the first
to the door you could be in a coma or
pretending you're in a coma so you don't
have to go to school
[ __ ] that the door bell goes off you
yanked that homemade IV out of your arm
and run to the door your mom's like I
thought you was dying
somebody would yell and halfway to the
door like it's for me you don't even
know you just trying to lay claim you
get there dude
it was Javas witnesses boy damn man
it's the Lord I was in Illinois like
rural Illinois who has wintertime right
and we'd eat we'd eaten some acid right
we got police cops in the convertible
they're like all right put the top up
get home you know they let us off video
and realize we're on LSD right so we go
drive and offer on these back roads and
dude the Sun is coming up and we find
ourselves on the exact same Road headed
right back where the [ __ ] cops are
and they're still sitting there no
[ __ ] wait
and we can't [ __ ] turn around now
can't see a cop and then stop we're
going we put the top back downs and we
thought there would be less car for the
cops to see is we buy so maybe they
wouldn't see us and we went as slow as
possible bro but bro the [ __ ] moment
were passing behind us hope they win
[ __ ] hear us probably doing four
miles an hour
that was the last thing I heard somebody
say before the lights went up yeah I got
all three got taken into the County
Courthouse really oh yeah I was on the
place I'm on the plane and man there is
somebody just just puff and butt out
into the air you know somebody just
doing you know body gas and I don't look
I don't mind smelling one or two you
know I'm human you know hell I'm even a
little curious you know but this dude
whoever this dude was just kept I mean
this guy was like a damn locomotive and
I got that big face piece you know it's
all really you know I could smell
somebody drinking a sprite from probably
about 60 feet away he's in the seat in
front of me so finally dude after about
the seventh time I [ __ ] woke him up I
woke I was like bro do Dustin you nasty
man and he looked at me he was gonna
maybe say oh that's not me and I said
that's you that's gross you're an adult
and bruh he didn't do it anymore
I felt at a certain point like it was
personal mm-hmm that make any sense yeah
totally and you had to play the role
that social assassin you you helped
everybody on the plane oh yeah I got to
go to the UFC fights
dude I hadn't been to a fight you know
since I've seen a couple honestly couple
sisters beating up my buddy that would
had a couple milkshakes in his hand
outside of us since an in Cincinnati
we're gonna call an interview the champ
ha Dustin Poirier oh look a bit of champ
jacks here
Tam's here what's up brother how are you
well bust it up you know but uh feeling
good the champ dude congratulations
brother
thank you do man it was awesome to see
you out there in the crowd yeah then I
would have tested positive for being a
straight [ __ ] and the audience to it I
was like it's so scared for us some
people got hurt I was praying for people
I texted the police at one point like it
was getting uh it was crazy man dude I
was so excited but I was gonna [ __ ] it
if anybody jumped in I was jumping in
you know I know you had my back
look I was gonna get knocked the [ __ ]
out boy I was ready to get knocked out I
even brought a pillow in my bag
first class on the airplane and first
class man look I don't get it all the
time you know some people probably
always get first class you know Ariana
Grande Chris D'Elia you know he got
first class he rich honor if you know
Chris D'Elia or not or Delia I heard a
rumor that he was at a coffee shop and
the table was uneven and he took a $600
and put it under the you know the bottom
corner of the table to fix it and left
it there when he left you know somebody
said he has a bathtub that has like a
little soap buffet on the edge of it and
Chris D'Elia
darling probably has blueberries so you
know soap that looks like so but it's
just crystal and it's not even really so
you know coconut soap or menthol
different type of varieties because they
he's like that and that's different man
I'm used to you know you get one kind of
soap you go in there and it's like Oh
what kind of soap do we have we got
[ __ ] soap that's it and crisp Dan
tony is a male comedian you know he is
you go to his house and let me tell you
his house it's crazy they have a
drawbridge dude it comes down and then
there's people drawing on it there was
two guys drawing like we're you're
drawing whatever he wants to die and you
get up there and there's an old man
standing there at the top of this hill
and he's like do you know pops one side
and I was like [ __ ] you dude it was
actually just a homeless guy had nothing
to do with Chris's place but you get
over his place man it's nice they got so
many stairs huh you know I thought I was
at my ku'Damm peak oh dude in his place
when you walk around in his his home is
it's like a castle I was like oh I think
somebody left their car running and uh
and they had like I don't want to say a
slave but they had some dude in Chains
and he's like oh no that that's the
dragon man they got a dragon down there
brother I was like oh okay it's a black
mirror episode yeah I remember at this
time of year when I was young in the
fall the carnival would come by and so
basically this guy that was operating
the rod he couldn't [ __ ] hear you he
would lock you in this kind of caged up
deal and then
he would started off one time they set
the ferris wheel up to close to a tree
oak tree you know or like a haunted
maple or something
you know but it looked like an oak they
had a wasps nests up there and dude I
don't know if I remember a more
harrowing experience dude you get on
this ferris wheel and then [ __ ] is just
taking you over and over again through
the wasps and every time we went through
every kid on the thing screaming crying
getting stung I remember [ __ ] Daniel
hit the air bro right I'll just jump
probably 90 feet off nobody I don't even
know what happened to him and god I
remember that that was miserable but
they gave everybody free cotton candy
this was our Vietnam October 31st it was
us against the world we were going to
get them baby snicker and we'd all be on
the back of moms car with the tailgate
down and she's rolling and we're on the
back of mom would roll up by the yard
and we would run and jump off that
tailgate into the yard as that car was
going just like I've been right out the
back of a c-130 man shoutout to all of
our servicemen and women just tumble
roll into the yard lose half your
[ __ ] candy in the roll whatever odd
word anything your sister would come off
at the last minute she only 2 years old
and then it was just every step you
could get through the dark grass to get
up to that front door and the mom is
right there and she got the big bowl and
she's dressed up like a little cat and
man you hope that snicker was in there
god I'm I loved Halloween say you were
in third grade and had that first recess
on your new playground the slide was
always a piece of [ __ ] bruh
honestly dude especially in the south
man they gave us metal slides some days
it was 97 degrees you got 70 kids trying
to play on a [ __ ] hot slide you'd
have one kid go down then the other 69
kids are now playing a game called EMTs
emergency medical tech
Nicias [ __ ] little hot legs Daniel
you know he'd be at the top and people
be like but you know Daniel Bryan he
makes his own choices dude and old
Daniel who had just recovered from the
burns from last year gonna give that 96
degrees slide a second chance the second
he hit the top of that slide when he sat
on it but you can hear the screaming
stuff as he would hit the slide and leg
room and all the other kids play an EMT
suddenly I want to say one more thing
yeah you mention this part about you
feel guilty because you haven't served
and I hear that from a lot of people but
what I wanted to say is first of all
it's not for everyone you don't need to
be in the military to serve what can you
do if you didn't serve well there's a
bunch of things you can do and one of
the best things you can do is you go
help you try and live a good life you
try and raise a good family you try and
build a good business you try and try
and just be a good person yeah because
by doing good things you're helping
America you're helping our economy
without a thriving economy in this
country the military doesn't wouldn't
even exist right so the one of the best
things you can do as a person's go out
and do your job really really well go
out and kick ass you're literally
building America and keeping America
strong so you're serving its in a weird
way as you say that I'm thinking you're
serving America in a way you're serving
America by being a good person by
putting other people employed by doing
fair business yeah if you're watching on
YouTube did you enjoy that clip well you
really would have enjoyed it if he was
watching on a TCL TV TCL is America's
fastest growing TV brand it's so fast
it's the Carl Lewis of television brands
it's that Florence Griffith visual
jointer
it's celebrating its 5th anniversary
from launching in the US markets I have
one of these at home and these suckers
are just I mean it's like having a Mona
Lisa on your wall that plays everything
you want follow TCL at TCL underscore
USA on Twitter and Instagram for more
details for more information about TCL
visit TCL usa.com
that's TCL
usa.com